camping on public property you'll see
counsel from both sides as they argue
before the state justices America and
the courts saturdays at seven p.m.
eastern time for Pacific on c-span next
the newly formed Progressive Caucus of
the 104th Congress congressman bernard
sanders and other members speak about
the caucuses agenda during this
50-minute news conference
ok
you
okay thank you all very much for coming
we're expecting some of the members to
be trickling in in a moment but let me
begin my name is Bernie Sanders
congressman from the state of Vermont on
november eighth in an election in which
only thirty-eight percent of the people
voted an election in which lower-income
people barely participated an election
dominated by big money and right-wing
radio talk shows the republican party
won a barely over fifty percent of the
vote with that so-called mandate the
republicans in the house are now
proposing legislation which if enacted
would cause intense pain and suffering
for tens of millions of americans most
primarily the weakest and the most
vulnerable people in our society at a
time when the gap between the rich and
the poor is growing wider when the
united states has the most unequal
distribution of wealth in the
industrialized world when poverty is
increasing when five million American
children go hungry the Republicans are
proposing to lower taxes on the wealthy
and cut back severely on programs needed
by the poor the elderly and our children
and what the Progressive Caucus is about
is saying no you won't get away with
that at a time when the Cold War has
ended when all over the world people are
thankful that the conflict that I gone
on for generations between the Soviet
Union and the United States is over when
russia wants to join nato when american
corporations are investing in tunes of
billions of dollars in china the
republicans want to increase military
spending and at the same time they want
to cut back on food stamps which go off
into hungry children on the WIC program
on the school lunch and breakfast
programs on childcare on affordable
housing and on help for the blind and
disabled frankly I don't think that that
is what America stands for tax cuts for
the richest people increased military
spending when the cold war is over and
causing more pain for the most
vulnerable people at our society now not
only will many of us in the Progressive
Caucus fight back against various
aspects of the contract for America but
we also intend to bring forward
alternative ideas that we think will
make sense to the American people we do
not believe that our economy is booming
when the real wages of American workers
are in decline when our manufacturing
base is crumbling as we lose millions of
jobs as corporations go to third world
countries so we think among other things
that we need a jobs program in America
to rebuild our cumbrian crumbling
physical and human infrastructure we
think that it is wrong that American
work is be asked to continue working for
four dollars and twenty-five cents
minimum wage we think it is appropriate
that the minimum wage be raised we think
we've got to re-examine our trade policy
many of us think that we have got to
change law to make it easier for workers
to come into unions so that they are
better able to stand up and protect
their rights but the bottom line of all
of us is that there are some of us in
Congress who do not believe that the
American people want to see fewer and
fewer wealthier and wealthier people
dominate our political and economic
lives and we
we are saying that some of us have not
forgotten the pain that is being
experienced by working people the middle
income people and poor people all over
this country some of us are not bought
and sold by corporate interests and big
money interests some of us were elected
to stand up and fight for those people
who don't have the power and what we are
saying today is that ordinary Americans
are not going to be forgotten and some
of us are going to stand here and fight
with them now let me introduce a
gentleman who has been a real fighter in
this Congress for many years major Owens
of New York we don't have the majority
of the votes on the flow of the house
that's obvious but we think we speak for
the majority of American people this was
an election where the oppressive
minority in my opinion scored a knockout
with a blitzkrieg but you had about 36
to 37 percent of the people voting for
House members so less than half the
people eligible vote came out to vote
they got a little more than half that so
there's no mandate on the other hand in
the exit interviews at the polls there
was a clear message that was sent we've
all read summaries of those exit
interviews some have chosen to get
amnesia about one of the messages that
the people set and that is there's a
great deal of anxiety about jobs a job
security white males upset because
they're not making enough money but they
have jobs but other people are worried
about losing the jobs they have in and
as there are too many people who don't
have jobs they're just unemployed so
we'd like to be the voice of the
majority what I call the caring majority
that's still out there the ordinary
people who are concerned about their
jobs and at every level we'd like to
challenge the contract with america in
terms of jobs starting welfare reform
the assumption is that there are jobs
that's a big lie you know I come from a
district with a large numbers of welfare
recipients and every job you produce I
can produce ten people are ready to go
to work right away they'll stand in long
lines to get jobs so if there were jobs
there would be fewer people on welfare
and we welcome and effort to create more
jobs so that people can get off welfare
and go to work they very much like to do
that contractor of America doesn't have
a jobs program nobody is speaking about
a job
program despite the fact that there's a
clear anxiety about jobs in this country
at this point we're at the point where
the global economics are taking over
there going to be a lot of upheavals and
changes and what we need is a policy of
job creation as a last resort by the
federal government this group will not
be afraid to offer that as an
alternative I don't think it's absurd at
all I think we'd better get ready for a
major problem major upheaval more
unemployment and producing jobs will
deal with that problem as well as many
of the other problems that are talked
about in the contract with america jobs
are the number one issue there's plenty
of work to be done work is not a job
unless somebody pays for it so the
federal government will have to have a
jobs program that's not big government
because ninety percent of what would be
produced to the jobs program would be
carried out by private industry if
you're going to build schools or take
care of the transportation
infrastructure most of things that are
done I've done through private sector is
not big government bureaucracies don't
build schools or road so we need to
however have a policy where we
understand that the economy is that two
economies as the economy for the prop
people who are making big profits the
stockholders and Wall Street that's one
economy for working people there's
another economy and that economy for
working people means they're losing more
and more jobs while there's a big boom
going on it's great that the boom is
going on it means that the nation has
wealth our wealth is increasing by the
way faster than our expenditures for
Social Security so we don't have to
worry about the future the wealth is
there it's a matter of how we going to
tap that well how we're going to use
that wealth for all the people we
propose to begin by providing jobs and
putting an emphasis on jobs everywhere
in this this process we challenge the
people who want to cut waste there's
plenty of waste in government plenty of
ways and they should start with the
entitlements that are not means tested
let's start with the farms program the
farm program you know nobody talks about
the crop insurance and the farm price
subsidies and the farmers home loan
mortgages were we talking about 50 to 60
billion dollars of entitlements that are
not means tested nobody wants to talk
about the waste that that the contract
with america proposes respect to defense
we need to give people a peace dividend
a tax cut which is a peace dividend
cutting the expenditures receive of
submarines
aircraft carriers and an unnecessary
bombing and buildup of forces are for
engagements that are not not going to be
near the future we speak for the the
Karen majority there blundering and
unorganized and they will out the
oppressive monarda to take over but
that's only a short-term adventure we
think that if we are clear voice often
clear alternatives we can win back what
is necessary to control this Congress by
providing the right leadership for the
care of majority Jerry Nadler is a
congressman from the state of New York
Attorney thank you very much during this
time of stepped up and downright vicious
assaults on low and middle-income
Americans the role of the Progressive
Caucus will become more crucial than
even before we agree with many of our
colleagues and with the with many of the
observations in the press that the
electorate is angry the election showed
that it's a fact that cannot be denied
of course the voters are angry millions
of our constituents remain unemployed
eighty percent of wage earners earn the
same in real dollars or substantially
less than they did 20 years ago even
among those who are employed millions do
not have health care of course the
electorate is angry will massive
sweeping cuts and agencies that help the
poor improve the lives of these
Americans I don't think so well
establishing orphanages for the children
of teenage mothers improve the lives of
these Americans I don't think so will a
repeal of the assault weapons ban
improve the lives of these Americans I
don't think so and I venture to guess
that the electorate that doesn't think
so either I for one am confident that
whatever part of the Republican contract
may get passed into law if any will not
it's all a fraud it will not help the
basic problem in the economy of the
American people which is that jobs are
too few that good jobs are too few that
eighty percent of the people as I said
are getting lower or equivalent wages
than 20 years ago that people are
insecure about their own jobs that five
of the largest corporations in the
United States have laid off
three hundred twenty-five thousand
people in the last four years we are
proposing instead that the Democratic
Party offer a real alternative so that
when the electorate the angry electorate
sees that the Republicans proposals do
not help them they will turn to an
intelligent progressive alternative that
we will offer instead of to something
that no one can predict an intelligent
progressive alternative is to create
jobs to create useful jobs to invent to
invest in the infrastructure of this
country where we are investing in
infrastructure and public infrastructure
now at the rate of one twelfth of our
competitors of our economic competitors
abroad there's one other interesting
fact we are told very often that these
facts lowering wages lack of good jobs
this is a result of the globalization of
the economy and it's just the fact we
can't do much about well the fact is
that this bimodal distribution of income
with twenty percent are getting richer
and eighty percent are getting poorer is
true in the United States and it's true
in Great Britain which had the
thatcherite equivalent to the Reagan
policies and most of the rest of Western
Europe you don't have that great
disparity in income and you don't have
stagnant or lowering wages countries can
go in another course and I am delighted
to join in co-sponsorship of congressman
Owens jobs bill for infrastructure and
I'm delighted to work with the
Progressive Caucus to turn back the
draconian and ill-conceived deference
that will be proposed by our colleagues
in the 104th Congress and instead work
toward an agenda that will provide an
alternative to truly improve the quality
of life for America's what essentially
is a congressman from New York said I
was going to be heavy on New York here
today but I think there's a lot of other
people who are not here at this press
conference mother parts of the country
do you support this initiative as well I
too would like to make the observation
that there are a number of points
obviously that were important about the
previous election important among them
is the fact that first of all most
people stayed home most people didn't
participate
it was eligible to vote did not
participate and those who did very often
express their anger and anxiety
Secretary Rice has called the this group
of people the anxious class and I think
that that is an appropriate appellation
for this group of people they consist of
the majority of Americans they consist
of most of the people that I represent
in the 26 congressional district in
upstate New York they are anxious about
their future they're anxious about their
jobs they're anxious about their ability
to provide for their children they're
anxious about the ability of their
children to get decent jobs and to have
an increasing standard of living and the
fact of the matter is that for the last
20 years the standard of living of the
majority of Americans has either been
stagnating or declining now a lot of
people have been making this observation
the revolt of the leads is of the book
that's out recently that makes that
point in addition to a number of other
people who have made that point over and
over again but that point doesn't seem
to have set in here in the Congress of
the United States that people are
anxious they are fearful they are deeply
concerned about themselves about their
families at about their future because
their economic conditions are not
improving and in fact they are declining
people have to work harder they have to
work longer to members of the family
have to work now to support what one
member was able to support a couple of
decades ago and this condition is not
improving it is in fact getting worse
day after day it is the responsibility
of this government to address these
conditions if we fail to address them
there will be additional unrest in this
society and that unrest will express
itself at the poles and elsewhere people
are anxious and they are deeply worried
about their future and when those
conditions exist they are going to react
in accordance with them we need jobs we
need more jobs and we need better jobs
we need jobs that are going to pay a
living wage so that people who are
employed can support themselves and
their families and what we're discussing
here today is legislation which will
provide for investment in America's
future the kind of investment that is
being engaged in in Japan in Western
Europe and elsewhere throughout the
industrialized world only in the United
States do you
find the failure of the government to
recognize its responsibilities for
transportation systems for waters
distribution sewer treatment facilities
all of these are essential to economic
growth and development in major parts of
this country water supply systems were
laid down either late in the last
century or early in this century they're
leaking at the rate of fifty to eighty
percent sewer treatment plants are aging
and becoming ineffective industry will
not locate in areas where there is not
adequate water supply and distribution
systems where there are not adequate
sewer treatment facilities where there
are not adequate transportation
facilities this legislation that we are
proposing will provide that kind of
investment in the future of America so
that we can produce the kind of jobs
that people will need to support
themselves and we do need an increase in
the minimum wage and we do need an
increase in investment of education and
this legislation addresses itself to
those needs as well counteracting this
of course even if we were successful
counteracting this of course is the
Federal Reserve the Federal Reserve
continues to move in a direction which
is opposed to economic growth and
development which fails to recognize
that the majority of Americans are
working for less and that their standard
of living is either stagnating or
declining that makes it even more
necessary for the Congress of the United
States to engage in these kinds of
investment practices to to create a
stronger nation internally and one that
will provide economic opportunity for
all of our citizens and I think that
it's important for us those of us who
are of a progressive been particularly
to provide an alternative to the
initiatives of the new Republican
majority and also to form a nucleus
around which a critical mass can evolve
over a period of time this is not going
to happen overnight obviously but there
has to be a beginning and there has to
be a central location there has to be a
nucleus around which this kind of
activity can develop and a majority can
begin to reform itself based upon true
rest of democratic principles Elop
recovery is congressman from Hawaii
Aloha good morning everybody I come here
is a Democrat representing the
southernmost state in the Union I hear
that the south is going to the
Republicans but it's obviously not true
the southernmost state is Hawaii in
Hawaii one Democrat across the board and
we won across the board because we ran
as Democrats Harry Truman said if you
talk like a Republican and act like a
Republican and run like a Republican
don't be surprised if people vote for a
Republican we have to do is stop
imitating the Republicans and start
running as Democrats again that means
running on behalf of people not running
over people somebody said this is a
contract on America I think that's true
and I think that you can take the the
president's phrase about putting people
first and you can see what the
Republican motto is cut people first cut
their throats that's what's going on
right now we have to take him on
directly and take welfare so-called
welfare what about corporate welfare
Donald Trump gets to deduct a hundred
percent while he's bankrupt he's told he
has to survive in five hundred thousand
dollars a month five hundred thousand
dollars a month you want to see swine at
the trough just go on up to New York
City and see Donald Trump his big deal
last year's picking on Indians because
they're gambling he wants to keep the
Indians out of gambling but I notice all
the Republican supervisors in Orange
County couldn't wait to gamble with
everybody's money out in Orange County
you can't even you can't even decipher
you have to be an astronomer to try and
decipher what kind of derivatives those
clowns were betting on in orange county
and now in one and with the chief of the
Board of Supervisors out there said we
don't even know where this money is
coming from but we're making millions
now that's the level that we're dealing
with and I think that's the way we have
to take them on now I'd be delighted I
hope we have these these opportunities
down and special
others to debate mr. Genrich and others
and economics it's amazing we have a new
intellect now on the speaker of the
house I hope we get a chance to debate
will talk about wages will talk about
people having a real chance we'll talk
about packs will talk about who gives
money to who and we'll see how it works
out when I was campaigning in the last
election go before business groups and
they said they want the deficit down
well we did that we brought the deficit
down in absolute numbers we brought it
down in percentages business people back
home either didn't believe it didn't
want to believe it or didn't care they
wanted to see it in their paychecks they
wanted to see it up front what we should
have done was passed the 60 billion
dollar investment in America two years
ago at the same time that we were
passing the deficit reduction bill I
voted for that and we carried out and
did what we said we were going to do
with the deficit at the same time we
should have been making the investment
now how do the Republicans propose to do
if they want to slow down read this
contract see what it says they want to
slow down the deficit reduction they
won't increase investment but where are
they doing it with Pentagon socialism
that's where they're gonna do it they're
gonna take care of the corporate pirates
then are going to come in not investing
in the average ordinary American now
next time we get together i'll have
another sermon for you I don't want to
go on right now because I know you're
probably anxious to ask us how we're
gonna pull all this off well my attitude
is and I hope it's going to be the
attitude of President Clinton when he
takes that fistful of veal pens out now
we got him where we want them and that's
the way it should be at long last we're
going to have a genuine battle on ideas
a genuine battle on where this country
should be going and how we should get
there I'm looking forward to it I can't
wait for a special orders they can't
wait for some of these bills to come up
I can't wait for the Republicans that
start backing down we were supposed to
work a hundred days straight no way I
understand it we're gonna come in on
Wednesday maybe Thursday morning take
the weekend off to go home and tell all
the folks how good
we're doing on that first hundred days
so much for that promise I understand
but listen to my good friends on the
Republican side of the Rules Committee
we're supposed to have open rules we
want to have all the amendments but I
understand the first thing we're to have
is a closed rule no I was I never was
for that in the first place so I don't
have to worry about it i'm gonna ask
them what kind of rules they're gonna
have is the first rule going to be an
open rule or not and if it's not then
they back down from that one and if
we're going to have the Congress operate
under the same laws as everybody else in
the country I expected speaker Gingrich
then will welcome the union organizers
from the Service Employees Union when
they come in to organize his office and
I expect every Republican and every
Democrat in the Congress will be
welcomed in the union organizers and
they'll be welcoming the OSHA people I
understand that some of our Republican
friends want to sell one of our
buildings well do you think we're
meeting the fire and safety standards in
this room right now hell of a fire broke
out now in this room so everybody be
trampled to death that may result in
general cheering and approbation
throughout the rest of the country but
your families might have some
reservations about it now I think what's
going to happen as soon as we apply all
the laws and rules is we're going to
have to spend billions more on more
government buildings in order to take
care of that cut staff that the
Republicans say they have so this is
gonna be fun this is gonna be
informative this is gonna be great this
is going to give an opportunity American
people see some real politics in action
see some some real joining of ideas and
i can't wait for it and i look forward
to a speaker Gingrich and the rest of
the crew coming in they're getting in
there down with us on the floor and him
coming out there saying god Neil if I'd
only realized before hand I'd have been
with you Livia Velasquez congresswoman
from you thank you good morning to
everyone and I am very proud to be here
this morning to embrace this legislation
and I will welcome our speaker and the
president bill clinton to support this
legislation
American public in this country they
want to change welfare as we know it
well we are presenting today the real
solution to welfare as we know it change
will be the buzzword here in Washington
this week however I am very happy that
at least one institution will survive
the conservative on onslaught of the
104th Congress the Progressive Caucus it
will fall to Congress persons like those
here this morning to keep alive the
faith in a more just and equitable
future this caucus will also bear the
responsibility of speaking truthfully
about the new majority in Congress and
their plan for the nation quite simply
the circle contract with america is a
hoax it's supposed to be a problem for
working people a middle-income families
yet its prime beneficiaries will be the
wealthy and the privilege what the
people need our jobs and security what
they get is the capital capital gains
tax cut a giveaway for the rich its
measures like the job creation and
invest in America Act there are the
medicine for an ailing nation instead of
the bankrupt trickle-down theories of
the 80s we offer a direct investment
initiative for denied ease and the next
century a million jobs a year a
community development school enhancement
occupational training and health
improvement these are the remedies that
working families have looking for to
their government not rhetoric just
common sense solutions Thank You Cynthia
McKinney is a congresswoman from Georgia
I'll just say that as you can see we're
a pretty colorful Bunch and but the
bottom line is that the Republican
contract on America is going to be
challenged and the Progressive Caucus is
going to challenge them every step of
the way now the most important component
in all of this the bottom line is that
we have to take our message out to the
people and that means that we're going
to have to organize in our own districts
we're going to have to enfranchise new
voters and new people bring them into
the political process
what we saw was some people are counting
it as a mandate but we really saw a lot
of people choose to stay home and we've
got to bring those people in and that's
why this progressive caucus is going to
go out into America with this message
with this challenge and we're here to
debate as you can see this is a quiet
and shy crowd but if coax they might be
prepared to answer a few questions yeah
the contract will be challenged tomorrow
in the first day of 104th um wants the
respondent tomorrow is the is well I
think tomorrow is going to be dealing
with among other things the rule 33 pins
taxes with Rita's yeah alright I think
one of the clear goals of the
Republicans is to protect the wealthy
and to slash programs the working people
poor people and middle-income people
need and one of the ways you do that is
to say that it is impossible make it
very very difficult to raise taxes now
at a time in which we already have an
extremely regressive taxes them at a
time in which corporations for example
are contributing fifty percent less to
the federal coffers than they did 40
years ago and rich people have enjoy
huge tax breaks what you want to do is
protect those people and make it very
difficult to pass taxes taxes in
themselves are not an evil the question
is where is the money going and who is
paying and I think I speak for everybody
up here and many other people who say
that it is not wrong to ask those people
who can best afford to pay more in taxes
to do something but other people let me
just add one thing on that the
Republican proposal is to require a
three-fifths vote of the house and sent
it to to raise income taxes only income
taxes not excise taxes so progressive
taxes you would need a three-fifths vote
to raise regressive taxes that don't tax
the rich more than middle and low-income
people you would not need a three-fifths
vote to raise so excise taxes perfect
example secondly we're going to be
asking a lot of questions
for example we're going to be asking a
question what about corporate taxes do
are we really saying that of the major
corporations that paid less than a
hundred thousand dollars or no in income
taxes last year and no income taxes at
all because of their tax loopholes that
we shouldn't raise that it should take a
three-fifths vote to raise their taxes
do we really want to say that for the
corporations that are busy exporting
American jobs abroad that we it should
take a three-fifths vote if we want to
tax to raise the tax on their earnings
from abroad so as to put a heavier
burden on their desire to export
American jobs abroad why should these
require a special supermajority vote
which is almost impossible to attain
when to raise an excise tax which
everybody low-middle income low-income
middle-income rich pay the same a
regressive tax would only take a
majority vote and finally and obviously
it's unconstitutional I just want to
make a little point on on this what what
is being discussed here really is
couched in the language of transferring
responsibility back to the local level
and decision-making activities back to
the local level couched in that kind of
language is actually what is actually
happening is passing the cost back to
the local level anyone who has ever
owned a home knows that the most
oppressive tax is the real property tax
local real property and school taxes
local real property and school taxes and
local sales taxes across this country
have been going up now for more than a
decade and you can trace it back to
among other things the the abolition of
federal revenue sharing when the federal
government eliminated that act of
transferring back to the localities some
of the tax revenues that were raised at
the local level that forced local real
property tax is up and at the district
that I represent which consists largely
of homeowners and people who pay real
property taxes and school taxes the most
oppressive tax the most hated tax the
most regressive tax the most unfair tax
the property tax and when the
Republicans talk about having a
three-fifths majority to deal with
progressive taxes here at the federal
level what they're really talking about
is raising local real property taxes
back home let me give you an exact
example of that because the question is
a good one what are we going to do
tomorrow will challenge each each one of
these things I hope they're going to
raise tomorrow at least rhetorically the
the question the balanced budget
amendment they are going to balance the
budget all right on the backs of local
taxpayers city county state taxpayers if
you just take their what welfare
proposal in Hawaii I'll give you a
specific example the money they would
take approximately nineteen thousand
children who are now receiving benefits
of one kind or another away they'd be
left on their own in Hawaii I want to
indicate over the past decade we've had
the lowest unemployment in in the entire
country so it's not as if people weren't
looking for jobs we have a high cost of
living in Hawaii for reasons that I'd be
glad to go into detail with you but the
fact is is that the cost of living is
much higher than it is on the mainland
and so our employment and our employment
nonetheless has been very very high
we've had difficulties because of the
high cost of living and seeing to it
that people even though they are working
are able to to earn enough money to stay
off of some kind of welfare assistance
food stamps etc or section 8 housing in
which you receive a subsidy in order to
be able to put shelter for yourself and
your family we have 19,000 off the off
the rolls the money that the Republican
contract proposes to return would take
care of 24 of those kids if they had to
go into an orphanage if they had to go
into foster care I have some some
experience with that having written the
legislation on that and head of the
committee that dealt with that in Hawaii
during the 1980s during the Reagan era
and I can tell you that there is not a
surfeit of foster parents out
qualified foster parents they are very
difficult situations to deal with and
the amount of money that would be coming
back would inevitably force the people
of Hawaii to tax themselves in order to
take care of the Republican transfer of
responsibility without a commensurate
transfer of funding yes majority anymore
and Republicans are gonna be bringing up
everything tomorrow under closed rules
is there anything that you can actually
do other than your debate you know what
time they give you for debate to block
any of these things do you have any
other strategy than that well we will
attempt to seriously challenge that kind
of provision the three-fifths for the
passage of any tax bill because that
cuts away at the one-man one-vote
provision you know if you can do that on
any legislation then they'll do it again
on some other favorite piece of
legislating we can't allow that to
happen I will do what we can with our
numbers but the important thing is the
message to the American people Newt
Gingrich you know ten years ago was in
the minority very much so not only in
the minority in general terms but in his
own party was in the minority he put
forth ideas and and and and clearly was
able to rally a core of people around
him to to gain some momentum to push
those ideas within his own party it's
it's it's important to Democrats offer
an alternative to the American people
let them know exactly what's going on
and he can only do that by fighting
vigorously on the floor the house we
hope I'll leadership will fight
vigorously but if they don't we
certainly will be there two ways to
fight you y'all have been talking about
some of the specifics that you'd like to
pursue your fellow Georgian the incoming
speaker has been staying over and over
again though that 40 years of big
government big spending has
it's time to try something new something
different what do you say to that well
everything that he says hasn't worked
there are some things that haven't
worked but there are some things that
have worked and we have to acknowledge
the fact that what mr. Gingrich did was
produce a marketing tool and that tool
was the contract with america and with
that tool and of course his special
interest slush fund that he had on the
side to finance his Republican majority
he was able to to achieve exactly what
he wanted to achieve our role now is to
look at what he is doing to agree with
those things that are right and too
vividly disagree with those things that
are wrong to take the to the American
people the alternatives the differences
in what it means to be a Democrat and
what it means to be a Republican and to
spell it out very clearly and of course
to say it in words that are clear and
understandable to the people I'd like to
make a point about that 40 years of big
government if you listen to Newt
Gingrich you would believe if you knew
nothing about the way the American
government works that that government is
controlled exclusively by the house of
representatives of course we know that
that isn't true this big government was
presided over by the by the
administration's of Nixon Ford Reagan
and Bush what were they doing all the
time that they were in the White House
when although this big government
activity was going on that gives the lie
to the the Gingrich propaganda Gingrich
focuses only on those aspects of the
American experience that seemed to
substantiate his peculiar point of view
and he sets aside the majority of that
experience he sets aside the fact that
we've had all of those Republican
administrations and that they have
systematically and conscientiously
dismantled the the war on poverty for
example created back in the Johnson
administration they would have people to
believe that the program's enacted in
the 1960s in this country
have run continuously through right up
to nineteen ninety-five of course we
know that isn't the fact we know what
Nixon did to them we know what what Bush
and Reagan and and and Ford did did to
those programs he wants people to forget
that during the decade of the 1980s six
years of that decade the Republican
Party controlled not only the White
House but the United States Senate as
well so let's be careful about what we
let Gingrich get away with he is very
discriminating and what he wants the
people to understand and believe but
it's our responsibility to give them the
full truth and the complete set of facts
I'd like to just add that what what we
are really about to see I think is
special interest anarchy where these
people want to come in and just tear
everything down and everything doesn't
deserve to be torn down let me all just
also just say that the Republicans Newt
Gingrich talks about the elites of this
country well he represents the elites of
this country and the Republican Party
represents the elites of this country
what about the rest of us and so at
least within the Progressive Caucus
we've got 30 or 40 of us who are
concerned about the rest of us and we're
about to fight for them I also would
like to add you know when you mention
new ideas coming from Gingrich I don't
see those nukes idea we have to go back
to the 12 years of ronald reagan and
bush you know what they did was to
eliminate a lot of social programs in
this country at the expense of working
families and children and poor women in
this country and also what the only
thing that we got from them was to
quadruple the deficit and that's what
we're going to get again yes
you're you tart having 30 or 40 people
in the caucus that's not even a majority
of the Democratic Party in the house
what type of internal debate do you
expect to have with your fellow House
members we see the DLC we see what's
happening the White House and then on
the same track as you guys are let me
answer that in two different ways I'm
not partying I'm innocent but let me
suggest respectfully that you're missing
the main point and I think major ones
made that point a little bit earlier the
truth of the matter is in my view that
we are going to change America and
restore sensible priorities so the
government works for ordinary people
rather than the wealthy and the powerful
not by backroom dealings and caucuses
and meetings in this building we're
going to bring about that change when
millions of elderly people stand up and
say no you're not going to slash
Medicare and poor people stand up and
say no you're not going to slash food
stamps and working people say no you're
not going to lower taxes for the rich
and raise my property taxes or my health
care expenses so ultimately while we
have got to fight in almost guerrilla
warfare day after day against every one
of these or virtually every one of these
proposals which comes down the pipe
while we have got to present and provide
intelligent alternatives perhaps the
most important thing that we can do is
say the tens of millions of Americans
who don't vote who don't participate in
the political process that we are with
you and that we want you to stand up and
to fight for your kids and your parents
and your own lives and that we want to
work with you that maybe we can be a
little bit of light in the darkness in
telling people don't give up on the
political process because when working
people and elderly people and poor
people give up we know who fills the
vacuum and the people who fill the
vacuum are the rich and the powerful who
contribute not only to the Republican
Party in all due respect I might say to
the Democratic Party the candidates all
over America that's the group of people
or
the politics and economics of this
country we don't concede we don't can
see that we have no power here and the
backhauls and smoke filled rooms of the
house even the progressive caucus
members are members of other groups
black caucus is represented here and we
expect to provide a clear and forceful
alternative and have it endorsed by the
Black Caucus the Hispanic Caucus is
represented here we expect to go to them
and have it indoors women's caucus is
represented we expect to drive for a
majority of the Democrats in the kind of
things that the kind of alternatives
that we propose there's one other
element on this and I think this is
where you're going to have to take the
question to the president as opposed to
us at the house per se if there's a veto
you have to get two-thirds they were
talking before about three-fifths try
getting two thirds mr. Bush exercised
his veto pen and by and that as he
should if that's what he believed he's
the president united states that's the
way the Constitution is set up you
exercise the veto you have to overcome
with a two-thirds vote it's one thing to
have the majority it's another thing to
be able to get a two-thirds vote in the
Congress if the president vetoes the
bill and that's where when you get 30 40
50 60 80 and 90 people together when you
can talk legislation with them and let's
face it up here a lot of people can't
came into this Congress bragging about
the fact that they didn't know anything
about legislation that they don't know
anything about the committee's that
they're being assigned to that the less
they know the easier it is to vote I
would I expect that that's true but
there's a lot of us in here a lot of us
in here understand that legislation
requires us we are duty bound and
obligated to speak with with our fellow
members here in the Congress not all of
whom we agree with on every issue in
every aspect it's a little bit arrogant
to think that you're going to get people
to vote with you for your reasons the
essence of a good legislator is to get
people to vote with you for their
reasons and so what we're going to do is
try to appeal to our fellow members of
Congress and to the president the united
states that asking him first to exercise
his veto pen exercises veto power and
then we in turn will appeal to other
members both of our democratic caucus
and
the independent caucus whenever we can
get him to sit down with us and uh and n
2 into a republican friends to ask them
than to consider the question of the
veto and whether or not we can appeal to
the interests that they see the
political and legislative interests that
they see with respect to whether or not
they want to overcome that veto that's
the real key the veto pen Oh a bit of a
subject change but what is on this
Congress's agenda when it comes to the
abortion debate in light of the recent
shootings in in Massachusetts what
should this Congress do but look at
somebody area here your show you about I
what this Congress should do well will
do maybe different things what it should
do obviously is to strengthen the
freedom of access to clinic bill to
clinic entrances bill that was passed at
the last year we should be asking the
administration to increase the
involvement of the FBI in investigating
these things we have to regard this as a
war on terrorism certain elements
certain elements of the anti-abortion
movement not most of it but some
elements have adopted a frankly terror
terroristic strategy no different from
some of those who were blowing up the
World Trade Center in Manhattan or and
and and other acts of terror and we have
to fight this regard it as a war on
terrorism because we cannot permit even
the abortion issue aside we cannot
permit anybody in this society to decide
that they because they have a superior
moral insight or superior intelligence
to everybody else in the country are
going to determine the policy of the
country regardless of what the majority
that people say the majority the
Congress says and so forth and that's
what we're going to be trying to do and
I would suspect that even many of the
anti-choice members will support crack
down on on terrorism because to allow
this to go on to allow that fringe of a
movement or that element of a movement
to get its way is obnoxious and
intolerable and democratic society and
also would encourage people who feel
strong about other issues to do the same
so except the other Kenny want to
respond people I just wanted to say that
one way to put him into this that won't
cost any money in addition to the things
that representative nadler outlined but
that won't cost any money is for those
who have been hyping the height to just
be quiet to sit down be quiet and stop
this anti-choice anti woman hysteria
that has taken over some of the airwaves
another thing is that those people who
are in leadership positions in the
Republican Party who happened to also be
anti-choice need to speak out and say
that this is not acceptable behavior we
do not condone this and they need to
speak out against it I haven't quite
frankly haven't heard our speaker to be
speaking out against it and also we
encourage the religious leaders in this
country to speak out on this issue to
talk about to pressuring pressuring New
York fellow Democrats pressuring the
White House the question is is there
anybody in the Democratic leadership
whether it's in the White House for
whether it's Dick Gephardt in the
leadership or even in the Senate that's
listening is anybody really listening to
you you have any of everyone you're the
best of my knowledge as a member of the
Progressive Caucus and as anybody at the
White House listening to you we will be
we have met will meet with the president
we think that some of the things that
Secretary of Labor rice talked about
when he talked about corporate welfare
what are you saying is before you throw
poor children into orphanages and cut
food stamps look at what the ripoffs the
corporations are getting so we think
righteous there but I think again to the
degree that we are forceful we're going
to be able to rally a lot of decent
members of Congress to do the right
thing rather than go over to the right
because they're not hearing a
progressive point of view
too scared the White House is scared
it's moved to the right gig tax cuts and
so on and so forth a DLC I mean that
seems to be the movement of the
Democratic Party under bill clinton
white why do we expect they're going to
listen to you because we think that in
grassroots America we represent the hell
of a lot more working people and poor
people than the DLC does I'm just
following up on the heavier numbers
going up and down Jove account just how
many members you'll have this we have
approximately 30 minutes and how many
did you have before the approximately 30
members but we haven't done our act of
organizing I think the main thing is not
Justin well we actually I think the main
point is it is perceived in America
today that there is a vacuum in terms of
responding to the rush limbaugh's and
white in right-wing Republicans what we
intend to do is not only stand up and
fight or present alternative ideas work
with the unions work with the women's
organizations work with the
environmental groups and if we can rally
grassroots America the people here are
politicians they listen and I think they
would rather move in a fair and honest
way rather than a right-wing way and our
job is the rally that public opinion all
right we've got a maybe just two more
minutes reforms that the Republicans are
going to be proposing tomorrow you
mentioned the three-fifths rule which
you will oppose but what about some of
the rules changes that they're proposing
for Congress or are you gonna support
one more specifically well for example
they have a whole raft of rules changes
and prodding not changing the
Congressional Record not changing
committee transcripts open committee
meetings and also this big bill to apply
labor laws and affirmative action laws
to Congress would you all support those
measures I'm gonna believe the house
arrest let me see let me let me say one
thing some of what they're doing is not
is the uncontroversial things that
you're mentioning are nice housekeeping
and I I would be surprised if too many
people oppose them this this bill to
apply most of the laws to the Congress
for instance which is now part of the
contract with america the
Republicans were instrumental in
blocking last year after the house
passed it the sweat was at the sweat
there's the sweat jays bill after the
house passed it they the Republicans
blocked it in the Senate because they
simply didn't want the Democrats to get
credit for anything so that's a
democratic proposal which we passed last
year and of course we're not going to
oppose it this year okay maybe last
question thing yes young girl given
everything that you've said on various
issues why isn't your jobs bill already
dead on arrival I think there is no
question on a number of issues we have
an uphill fight but i think is others
have made the point just because
tomorrow you don't have a majority does
not mean to say you don't come forward
with ideas that are right and which
makes sense to ordinary working people
that's how change takes place to my mind
the overwhelming majority of american
middle class and working people are
terribly concerned about the decline in
our standard of living the exodus of
decent paying jobs to China Malaysia and
elsewhere it is insane to my mind that
Amtrak has just thrown 5,000 workers out
on the street when everybody here knows
we've got to significantly improve our
mass transportation and our rail system
that affects Vermont virtually every
state in the Union Washington DC as I
understand it is talking about cutting
back on libraries and at the same time
you have politicians saying how
important it is to have an educated
society what are we talking about when
we're saying we don't have monies to
maintain libraries whether we're laying
off teachers so I think we have the
ideas we gotta fight as hard as we can
we're going to rally support outside of
this building and inside this building
and we are going to prevail we have a
president of still learning and he needs
to hear our voices thank you all very
much thank you